perpetual motion machines are badly
named a true perpetual motion machine
doesn't just keep spinning forever if
you were to set an object spinning out
in intergalactic space in some ideal
true vacuum it would keep spinning
forever you just wouldn't be able to get
any useful work out of it
if someone actually built a perpetual
motion machine a true one it would give
out more energy than is put in enough to
overcome friction enough to overcome air
resistance enough to keep going until
mechanical failure and like a wind
turbine it would let you take some of
that extra energy for your own use there
are obviously some physics objections to
this the laws of thermodynamics always
hold true
this here is device made by Thomas Young
in 1807 it is the original two centuries
old from the archives of the Royal
Institution in London which is why I
have to wear gloves to touch it it's an
unbalanced wheel and there have been
many perpetual motion machines like it
there was a giant one in Los Angeles in
the early 20th century advertising a
cafe and according to Popular Mechanics
it kept going until there was a citywide
power cut
and there was an inventor in 1829 who
was sure that a carriage with conical
wheels would roll around the world till
time shall be no more they all work on
the same principle cheat the center of
gravity so it's always on one side
constantly unbalanced in the same
direction in this case if you draw a
line down the middle there are more ball
bearings on that side so that side
should be heavier and when one gets near
the top it rolls over so that side over
there
yeah it's constantly being pushed down
this doesn't work obviously and that's
why Thomas Young built this machine to
demonstrate that it's impossible there
may be more ball bearings on that side
but the ones on this side are further
away from the center no matter how much
you complicate it this wheel will just
rock back and forth and eventually
settle where the center of gravity is
lowest or where friction stops it but
imagine if perpetual motion machines did
work which isn't difficult to imagine
apparently there are all sorts of snake
oil companies who successfully sucker
investors into giving up surprising
amounts of money and then never produce
any actual proof of
working prototype there have been so
many attempts that both the US Patent
Office and the UK Patent Office refused
to even entertain the idea of perpetual
motion machines now you can argue
physics and thermodynamics all you want
but there is a more common-sense
argument against perpetual motion
machines against the idea of free energy
because regardless of how it's powered
whether it's an unbalanced wheel or
something else if you have a magic box
that can give out more energy than it
takes in what happens if you use a small
one to power a bigger one and so on and
so on and so on you could start with
something the size of a grain of sand
and rotate the earth with it
or what happens if you plug it into
itself if you have something that
multiplies the energy you put in then
after a few seconds you've got a bob
thank you very much to the Royal
Institution over on their Channel I'm
debunking three other types of petrol
motion machines along with someone from
their team go check it out